a few years ago bill gates lost the
number one spot on the billionaires list
to jeff bezos
and with his tech peers gaining tens of
billions per year
it looks like he's only going to be
trending down over the next couple of
years
after all elon musk managed to gain more
than bill gates entire net worth
in just 2020 alone despite this though
i think bill gates is still the number
one billionaire
and will continue to be the number one
billionaire for a long time to come
and here's why
well starting off when i say that bill
gates is the number one billionaire
i don't mean that he leads in any
specific category per se
if we look at wealth alone the title
would go to jeff bezos
and if we look at importance and
influence alone the title would likely
go to elon musk
but i'm not talking about any single
measure
rather i'm talking about bill gates from
an overall perspective
as from this view he still reigns
supreme by far
to illustrate this let's begin by
looking at the easiest measure
his wealth today he stands at about 130
billion dollars
and though that's the third highest in
the entire world jeff bezos is actually
a full 40 percent ahead of him
however there is one major point that we
should keep in mind
which is that the only reason bill gates
is at 130 billion dollars today
is because he chose to be there you see
bill gates chose to stop aggressively
growing his wallet over two decades ago
in 1994. ironically that's the same year
that amazon was started
meaning that bill gates was wrapping up
his journey when jeff bezos was just
starting his
anyways bill gates owned a full 45 of
microsoft when they went public in 1986
and he retained the vast majority of
that position up until 1994.
but starting in 1994 bill gates decided
to heavily scale back from his microsoft
ownership
in fact as of march 2020 he has watered
down his microsoft stake down to just
1.36 percent now this was definitely the
smart thing to do
as holding virtually your entire net
worth in one company
is not the best idea despite that though
that's basically what everyone else at
the top has done
with the exception of warren buffett if
bill gates didn't decide to play
conservative
like his peers he would be far ahead of
jeff bezos
today for instance let's say bill gates
only liquidated five percent of his
microsoft stake
for living expenses and very side
projects that every billionaire seems to
have today
bill gates could have easily retained a
40 stake in microsoft
considering their strong profitability
from day one
unlike many ipos today microsoft was
profitable
when they went public and they did not
go public to raise capital by
any means one of the main reasons they
even went public was to create a
long-term exit strategy
with that being said their market cap is
currently 1.65 trillion dollars
and a 40 stake would translate to a
whopping 660 billion
in fact bill gates only needed to hold
on to 11.5 percent
to still be number one today and who
knows where microsoft stock would be
today
if bill gates hadn't stepped down and
had continued to leave the company
i'm sure he wasn't oblivious to this
fact he saw a computer-filled future
way back in the 1970s so i'm sure he
knew that computers would only become
more dominant
as we crossed into the new millennium
and sure there was going to be ups and
downs and sideways movement
but the overall trajectory was surely
upwards
despite that he was simply satisfied and
wanted to focus on other endeavors
and that brings me on to my next point
which is that he is one of the only
billionaires who has had the heart to
call it quits
most billionaires end up working until
the day they die
just take a look at warren buffett he is
90 years old and is worth upwards of 90
billion dollars
yet he continues to just keep chugging
away
now of course a lot of this can be
explained by the fact that most
billionaires
love what they do and they don't feel
the need to quit
at the same time though there are many
other pleasures in life that they should
likely try out
as well bill gates stepped down from
being microsoft's ceo
right at the turn of the millennium in
january of 2000 at age 44.
he did take on the role of chairman and
chief software architect
but these were really more of an
oversight guidance role
as opposed to a hands-on role
concurrently
he founded the bill and melinda gates
foundation in 2000
and through this foundation he has
donated a total of 50 billion dollars
or the same amount of money that the
25th richest person in the entire world
has
on top of this bill gates has played a
full-time role
at his foundation and ensured to the
best of his ability
that his money was spent well it's one
thing to sign the giving pledge
and be willing to give 99 percent of
your wealth to charity
that itself is an extremely commendable
act but
bill gates has taken that to the next
level by dedicating the last 20 years of
his life
and likely the rest to set cause and the
results have been
extraordinary in the year 2000 the world
health organization
reported that 60 percent of worldwide
measles deaths occurred in sub-saharan
africa
by 2015 however measles vaccination
rates in several parts of africa
were higher than that of north america
i'm sure
anti-vaxxers in the us played a role in
that but this is nonetheless an
excellent achievement evidently bill
gates has not only made extreme sums of
money
but he has also given away extreme
amounts in effective manners
at the same time he has also not held
back on splurging
on his own life and living it to the
fullest he doesn't have 10 or 33 homes
or anything like that
but he does have one super awesome house
and
three modest vacation homes bill gates
main residence
is a 127 million dollar mansion located
in medina washington
the house tops 66 000 square feet with 7
bedrooms and 18.75 bathrooms
it also has a trampoline room and a
reception hall with capacity
up to 200 guests on top of this it also
has 6 kitchens
and a 23 car garage clearly bill gates
didn't hold back when building this
house
but at the same time it's not too over
the top
for instance it's nowhere near as lavish
as trump tower
and mar-a-lago or on bonnie's 2-billion
dollar skyscraper
similarly bill gates owns two super nice
gulfstream g650s
but it's no boeing 757 or airbus a380
both of which he could have easily
afforded as you can see
bill gates loves to indulge in nice
things but
these purchases are usually made with
practicality and use in mind
and he has little interest in being
opulent or flashy
moving on another sector that bill gates
shines in is of course his family life
in the world of billionaires and
celebrities scandals
divorces and artificial families are
commonplace
with bill gates on the other hand he has
been married to melinda since 1994
and has three kids the oldest being born
in 1996
and the youngest being born in 2002
considering that bill gates stepped down
from his position
as ceo in 2000 he was likely able to
spend significant amounts of time
with all of his kids as they were
growing up unlike most billionaires
take elon musk for example those
contributions to society
are outstanding the journey there was
not easy
by any stretch of the imagination it's
not uncommon for him to sleep in tesla
factories for extended periods of time
and he consistently works 100 plus hours
per week
while this is awesome for shareholders
the ev market
and the space market i'm not quite sure
that his family
really appreciates this behavior anyways
going back to bill gates
though he has likely been able to spend
large amounts of time with his kids
he has been very careful to not spoil
them in fact
he's only leaving behind a mere 10
million dollars per kid
or a total of 30 million dollars to put
that in perspective
even with bill gates 1.36 stake in
microsoft
microsoft stock only has to go up 29
cents for bill gates to make 30 million
so clearly not very much money for bill
at
all after all he's essentially giving
each child one dollar
for every 13 000 dollars he has it looks
like bill has really taken his friend to
warren buffett's advice
to heart leave your children enough
money so they can do anything
but not enough that they don't have to
do anything
at the end of the day i think we can
clearly pick out one pattern from bill
gates
that others at the top don't have which
is balance
mega billionaires generally excel in a
handful of areas
but drop the ball on most other things
they might be an outstanding businessman
or a leading salesperson but they're
oftentimes not the best parent or the
nicest person per se
however this is not the case with bill
gates
he made extreme amounts of money running
microsoft and could have made hundreds
of billions more
but when he started building a family he
scaled out
and over the years though he hasn't
spent his time in a 1958 house
driving a cadillac like warren buffett
he also hasn't splurged on dozens of
houses and toys
along the way finally with the time he
has left
he has tried his best to ensure that the
money he is donating is spent as
effectively
and as intentionally as possible and
though he may not be the best in any one
of these realms
he has tried his best to maintain a
balance and has made significant
progress
in all of them thus if you're aspiring
to be a billionaire
i think bill gates is the one to follow
do you guys think bill gates is a dope
billionaire
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think all the conspiracies
surrounding its name
is a shame and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one